hey really quick our sponsor Babel is
giving you 25% off when you use the link
under this video I recently went to
Italy I knew a very little Italian a
month ago but after spending just a few
weeks using the Babel language learning
app before the trip I was able to
confidently have conversations in
Italian while I was over there the
lessons were quick and easy I did it all
on my phone you don't waste time
learning things that aren't relevant and
you actually remember what you learn I'm
going to stick with it you should check
it out too and you'll get 25% off when
you use the link underneath this video
hey this is really funny a little
progressive media sort of inside
baseball that I think is is connected to
some of the broader issues that I've
been talking about there's a guy who has
a YouTube channel named Jimmy door and I
guess he doesn't like Sam cedar from the
majority report or at least he doesn't
get along with Sam or at least he
doesn't want his audience hearing about
Sam at least to some extent they've had
their disagreements over the years
there's sort of from different wings of
the american left i guess you could say
and jimmy dore has been caught
censoring sam cedars name in an
incredibly obvious and childish way from
a youtube upload in much the same way
that cultural critic and arbiter of
ideas dave rubin skipped over Sam's name
when one of Dave Reubens viewers brought
Sam's name up not long ago and it's
hilarious to see people on the I mean I
guess I'll say on the left and right
both employ the sort of same technique
to prevent sam cedars name from
appearing in their videos it's like the
the name that shall not be said it's
almost taking on some kind of like
dogmatic weirdly religious component in
a sense you can't you just can't say
Sam's name they don't like it so first a
reminder here's the hilarious moment
where dave rubin was taking audience
questions via what's called youtube
super chat and somebody submitted an
audience question asking dave to debate
sam cedar and dave rubin sort of mumbled
as soon as he saw Sam's name and just
moved on take a look hey Dave this is a
very brave move on your part kudos have
you heard about the SJW nonsense
III don't even care about those guys
does it really just honestly doesn't
matter so what was on-screen was a
message that said you should have Sam on
and destroy him and Reuben didn't even
want to say Sam's name instead saying oh
I don't care about those guys so that
was like a couple months ago so then
this week here is the same thing
happening with Jimmy door when a guest
mentioned Sam's name now this was a
guest not just some random viewer so
Jimmy door had to handle it a little bit
differently it obviously was part of the
initial recording but then Jimmy doors
team or Jimmy door I don't know who's
doing the editing over there edited out
Sam's name in a very obvious cut before
uploading the video this is amazing you
will hear them on Sam's show play the
audio which was and then the video which
was subsequently uploaded and you'll
notice that Sam's name was removed from
the edit in the video that was
eventually uploaded your show Sam show
or the Young Turks that's usually who I
go to for news your shows
so when Sam's name is mentioned there's
a flash on the screen which is a video
transition as we call it in video
editing and the met the moment where
Sam's mentioned is just completely
removed they play it again and check it
out Sam's name just scrubbed it's almost
like a redaction with a black marker I
mean on your show or the young turks
that's usually who I go to for news your
show Sam show or the Young Turks that's
usually who I go to for news your show
or the Young Turk and that's not even
the one that they talked about yeah and
then there's another instance of this on
Jimmy doors show they don't have the
comparison audio but it's another one of
these flashes where the guest appears to
say people like you and Sam cedar and
sam cedars name is again removed my
solution is for the bread tubers and all
the left tubers people like you to go
debate with these people and to get into
their algorithm so that people see the
other side of bread tubers and all the
left tubers people like you to go and
debate with these people and get into
their algorithms you can see the flesh
that's helpful if they could have their
jump cut that they put themselves that's
what a big but somebody said that that
was in the context of I think there
could have been another one listen this
I mean we we can talk about why this is
going on and and that kind of gets into
the internal drama between Sam and Jimmy
the the big takeaway is that this calls
more attention to it right this is the
Barbara Streisand effect which is named
for the Streisand effect is it I think
it was in the around the year 2000 or so
some paparazzi someone I think had
gotten a helicopter and taken pictures
of Barbra Streisand's big Malibu house
in in Malibu California and I guess
Barbra Streisand didn't want those
pictures published so I don't know if
she sued but she tried to get the
pictures suppressed and this caused more
attention to be drawn to the pictures
that maybe nobody even really would have
cared about I mean I don't remember in
the early 2000s how much people cared
about Barbra Streisand's house I
certainly didn't care about it at the
time but it just drew more attention to
it and it's the exact same thing that's
happening here Dave Rubin won't
interview me and now people are going to
his events and asking about me Dave
Rubin recently said I've lied about him
a bunch of times
he never cited what those lies were as a
result now people are continuing to go
to his events and ask about what lies
the David Pakman tell about you or
sending super chats or tweeting him or
whatever the same thing is happening
with Sam cedar people are all over dave
rubin and jimmy dore social media feeds
talking about sam saying debate sam on
and on if you don't want to make this a
big deal just ignore that sam was
mentioned this has happened with me
before there are periods of time where
my callers and people on live streams
and twitter and whatever they will just
hammer me with some question about some
video i did or whatever if i don't want
to talk about it i just ignore it
i don't call more attention to it and i
certainly would not do such an obvious
edit to remove the name of someone from
being mentioned in this way when people
even
call in to me and they say Jimmy door
this or that I don't care say Jimmy door
I if they asked me what do you think
about what Jimmy door said I say I don't
know I haven't seen it because I don't
watch his show it would be ridiculous to
go out of my way to cut his name out or
the names of other people and this is
sort of what I've been talking about
lately this problem on the left
if Jimmy door doesn't like Sam just
ignore the mentions of Sam but doing
this calls more attention to it it
generates more content around the fact
that this took place and I truly don't
get what the end game is here it doesn't
make any sense to me